Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to have a little taste of how
smart an AI can be these days. And it turns out,
these new AIs are not only smart enough to solve
some grade-school math problems, but get this,
a new development can perhaps even take a crack at
university-level problems. Is this even possible,
or is this science fiction? Well, the
answer is yes, it is possible…kind of.
So, why kind of? Let me try to explain.
This is OpenAI’s work from Oct 2021. The goal
is to have their AI understand these questions,
understand the mathematics, and reason about a
possible solution for grade-school problems. Hmm,
alright. So, this means that the GPT-3 AI might
be suitable for the substrate of the solution.
What is that? GPT-3 is a technique that can
understand text, try to finish your sentences,
even build websites, and more. So, can
it even deal with these test questions?
Let’s see together. Hold on to your
papers, because in goes a grade-school
level question. A little math brain
teaser if you will. And out comes,
my goodness. Is that right? Here, out comes
not only the correct solution to the question,
but even the thought process that led to this
solution. Imagine someone claiming that they
had developed an AI this capable ten years ago.
This person would have been locked into an asylum.
And now, it is all there, right in
front of our eyes. Absolutely amazing.
Okay, but, how amazing? Well, it can’t
get everything right all the time. Not
even close. If we do everything right,
we can expect it to be correct about 35%
of the time. Not perfect, not even
close, but it is an amazing step forward.
So what is the key here? Well, yes, you guessed
it right. The usual suspects. A big neural network
and lots of training data, the key
numbers are 175 billion model parameters,
and it needs to read a few thousand
problems and their solutions
as training samples. That is a big rocket,
and lots of rocket fuel if you will.
But, this is nothing compared to what is to come.
Now, believe it or not, here is a followup paper
from just a few months later, January 2022
that claims to do something even better.
This is not from OpenAI, but it piggybacks on
OpenAI technology as you will see in a moment.
And this work promises that it can solve
university-level problems. And when I saw
this reading the paper, I thought…really? Now,
grade school materials, okay, that is a great
leap forward, but solving university-level
math exams? Now we’re talking! That’s where
the gloves come off. I am really curious to see
what this can do! Let’s have a look together.
Some of these brain teasers smell very
much like MIT to me. Surprisingly short
and elegant questions, that often seem much
easier than they are. However, all of these
require a solid understanding of fundamentals,
and sometimes even a hint of creativity.
Let’s see. Yes! That is indeed right. These are
MIT introductory course questions. I love it. So,
can it answer them? Now, if you have been holding
on to your papers, now, squeeze that paper, and
let’s see the results together…my goodness. These
are all correct. Flying colors! Perfect accuracy,
at least on these questions. This is swift
progress in just a few months. Absolutely amazing.
So, how is this black magic done? Yes,
I know that’s what you’re waiting for,
let’s pop the hood, and look inside together.
Um-hm. Alright! Two key differences
from OpenAI’s GPT3-based solution.
Difference number one. It gets additional
guidance. For instance, it is told what topic are
we talking about, what code library to reach out
for, and what is the definition of mathematical
concepts, for instance, what is a singular value
decomposition. I would argue that this is not
too bad, students typically get taught these
things before the exam too. In my opinion, the
key is that this additional guidance is done in an
automated manner. The more automated, the better.
Difference number two. The
substrate here is not GPT-3,
at least, not directly, but Codex. What is
that? Codex is OpenAI’s GPT language model
that was fine-tuned to be excellent at one
thing. And that is, writing computer programs,
or, finishing your code. And as we’ve seen in
a previous episode, it really is excellent. For
instance, it can not only be asked to explain a
piece of code, even if it is written in assembly.
Or, create a pong game in 30 seconds. But,
we can also give it plain text descriptions
about a space game, and it will write it.
Codex is super powerful. And now, it can be
used to solve previously unseen university-level
math problems. Now that is really something.
And, it can even generate a bunch of
new questions, and these are bona fide,
real questions. Not just exchanging the
numbers, the new questions often require
completely different insights to solve
these problems. A little creativity I see!
Well done little AI! So, how good are these? Well,
according to human evaluators, they are almost
as good as the ones written by other humans. And
thus, these can even be used to provide more and
more training data for such an AI. More fuel for
that rocket. And, good kind of fuel. Excellent.
And, it doesn’t end there, in the meantime,
as of February 2022, scientists at OpenAI
are already working on a followup paper that
solves no less than high-school mathematical
olympiad problems. These problems require a solid
understanding of fundamentals, proper reasoning,
and often even that is not enough. Many of these
tasks put up a seemingly impenetrable wall,
and climbing the wall typically requires a real
creative spark. Yes, this means that these can
get quite tough. And their new method is doing
really well at these. Once again, not perfect,
not even close, but it can solve about 30 to 40%
of these tasks, a that is a remarkable hit rate.
Now we see that all of these works are
amazing, and they have their own tradeoffs.
They are good and bad at different things and
have different requirements. And most of all,
they all have their own limitations. Thus, none
of these works should be thought of as an AI that
just automatically does human-level math. However,
what we now see is that there is swift progress
in this area, and amazing new papers are popping
up not every year, pretty much every month.
And, this is an excellent place to apply The
First Law Of Papers, which says that research is
a process. Do not look at where we are, look at
where we will be two more papers down the line.
So, what would you use this for? Please let me
know in the comments below, I’d love to hear
your ideas. And also, if you are excited by this
kind of incredible progress in AI research, make
sure to subscribe and hit the bell icon to not
miss it when we cover these amazing new papers.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!